you know guys and it's core csgo is a
tactical game in game leaders and
coaches spend countless hours coming up
with a myriad of strats for each and
every single map but sometimes it's the
little stuff that can trip you up like
not buying a diffuser or burning to
death in your own Mali and flank will
close out map number one is fix beam to
a left 50 oh wait no what happened oh no
and so here we are with the top 10 this
place in CS co kicking off this list is
team Cocoa's invert @c bow pro league
season 9 in a match that was already
going to live on and infamy Wow invert
found himself in a 1v2 situation with
the bomb planted at B while setting up
his defense he tossed a molly on to
window and the rest is just well tragic
like invert could still witness they
can't press that molly they can't really
do anything they'll have me we've been
first was gonna happen there was no
other possible outcome
what what what it was that dude what is
that round coming in at number nine is
team liquids Costa at illega season one
in a tight 2v2 situation against c9
gusta found himself with the bomb as
time ticked away all he had to do was
plant it within four seconds but then
this happened and it's so important that
he co holds the line what are you doing
wide right so he throws a Molotov and it
takes about four seconds to get that
bomb planted so he throws the ball time
and that ends up costing
oh my lord that is not how you want to
start off a match or at this level here
that's just not a lot of fun making its
way in at number eight is SK gaming's
semi-final match against ninjas in
pyjamas at IEM Auckland 2017 having
found an early lead
the Brazilians look to widen the gap
even further if only they had just
diffused the bomb let this be a lesson
in just how critical communication is
and counterstrikes highest-level smoked
off molotov as well even though it's 10
seconds there's a chance no chance
tracking infect oh you're right he had
to get off me that's gonna be extremely
closely I'm gonna think that the huge
error they've miscalculated that they
didn't have to be anywhere near inside
of them tunnels they could've gone that
much sooner
yeah miscommunication of the defuse kit
the plan with the King could have caught
that before and looked like dragon had
conceded that smokes down the
incendiaries as well there was no chance
when you're already down thirteen two at
the half and oh and two in the group
stage a team kill is definitely not what
you need to turn things around
that's why captain mo of tyloo earns our
number seven spot on this list taking on
g2 at IEM Oakland 2016 tyler desperately
needed something to rally around but
that thing was not a team killed we
could say more about this play but we're
gonna let Semler take it from here
Bansi survives eight HP left on him and
while that smoke is still up the whole
captain bull oh that is unfortunate
that's painful it's like watching the
game car crash
you can't look I can't look away at the
number six spot is majus boy who's north
squad were taking on SK gaming at ESL
one cologne 2017 down 1510 on cash magic
had the perfect opportunity to extend
the map by planting the bomb after
taking out taco
instead this place serves as a PSA for
just how big of a role movement plays in
the game of csgo second of all time is
ticking and they might have just run out
of it
just has to do something it's done it's
over the pong come come
we just can't come through oh my word
what a disastrous way to end that round
it brings us no pleasure to inform you
that number 5 marks castas second
appearance on this list this time as a
member of counter logic gaming at
Dreamhack Valencia 2017 with CLG on the
cusp of advancing to the playoffs
Cousteau was the one tasked with the
defuse and everyone watching thought
that everything was wrapped up except it
wasn't just take a look at FNS his face
the man who actually had the defuse kit
you saw they even left this time of my
Kalani and rusty deep disconnected he
was good
Michael is confused oh yeah CLG ended up
losing the series in overtime when the
retake and that's it that's gonna be
over in the blink of an eye representing
this out the LG this is not this is
fantastic
coming in HoN at number four is cloud 9
at ESL esea pro league season one finals
during the summer of 2015 the North
American squad were on a tear making
three consecutive grand finals and
beating out multiple European
juggernauts in the process but even when
you're the best from na you're still na
at the tail end of the sixth round on
overpass against fnatic cloud nine just
needed to defuse the bomb to win
but I have no words to describe what
happened next perfect to stop these
diffuse he tosses it out there that's
gonna slow things down tries to Pinetop
skadoodle will get him and the orc
have they got time they're just gonna
sit up buddy-buddy oh my god no what is
happening you know you don't see that
too often I you know that's a soul
destroying round coming in at number
three is Cajon be with Astralis at the
MLG Columbus major while the Danes were
trailing in the first half of their
semi-final match against natus vincere
Cajun B & Co thought a lucky break when
na'vi left themselves no time to plant
the bomb all Cajun B had to do was stay
alive his reaction says the rest
shouldn't be talking to Ponte you can't
do it he went for the often steady
facing that what in God's name is he
doing he was hiding the pay have no idea
what's going on you can see the look on
his face he's realized what he's done
all he had to do is stay alive and he
didn't know you had one job Cajun beat
one job despite winning the e League
Atlanta major zip xtext the runner-up
spot on our list in a quarterfinal match
against Navi Navi were on map point in
round 30 of game number two being the
clutch master that he is zipping swated
patiently in a 1v2 and caught seized and
edward right where he wanted them that
is if he hadn't forgotten to line up his
shots
see the trend Eduardo's fabulous life
but if it went the other way around that
he probably went but now 16 to 14 now be
taken to duster hopping off the bomb at
number one his existence at Asus frog
winter 2015 down a map against an IP
Titans in-game leader was looking to
bring the French squad to match point
and in a 1v1 against ni P's maikelele
all existence had to do was hold the
diffuse with the pressure of the grand
final anything can happen
into the corner Freiburg Sean Michael
edit he's too late for it if the fuse
already my can't do a single thing
I don't think eh if I sit down was on PK
at the end no they put I'm a kid they
both haven't get existence he has this
in the bag he just doesn't realize how
close Michael Ealy is and Michael Layla
that was a gift well guys that's our
list for this week now if you didn't
already know we put out great content
each and every week on this channel and
if you're not subject well that's the
real missplay thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]